20 years that's how long xbox has been
with us
and like you this is a moment i always
look forward to
i love seeing the new games crossing my
fingers from my favorites to return
hoping for a few surprises most of all
though i love seeing
everyone around the world come together
and celebrate
what games mean to all of us and i think
you know this past year
they've meant even more thank you for
being with us today
thank you for the support you give us
and one another
xbox is turning 20. and i wouldn't be
here
if it wasn't for the friendships we've
had that whole time
at bethesda we believe video games do
one thing better than anything else
they transport us through art and
technology
there's real magic when you step into a
new world and can make it your own
we've traveled the worlds of elder
scrolls of fallout
and now for the first time in over 25
years
we're creating a new universe with
starfield
set hundreds of years in our future it's
an epic
about hope our shared humanity in
answering our greatest mystery it's a
game we've dreamt of playing
and it wasn't till now that we have the
hardware the technology and the team
who's hard at work at home to make that
dream a reality
we're excited to finally share our first
in-game
teaser and something to look forward to
[Music]
constellation starship frontiers
clear still go
they say the wonder is not that the
field of stars
is so vast but that we have measured it
you're part of constellation now part
of our family what you found
it's the key to unlocking everything
we've come to the beginning of
humanity's final journey
prepare for departure graviton loop
arrays
check
your space that's why we're here
to discover what's out there
[Music]
it is awesome to share with you for the
very first time one of the most
anticipated games
in the world from todd howard and the
team at bethesda games studios
a groundbreaking game and yes it's
exclusive